first century oncology is proud of their
world-class patient
satisfaction ratings and now they have
re-branded and leveled up
here's how
great news for 21st century oncology the
largest provider of radiation oncology
services
in the u.s with three locations right
here in the valley
21st century oncology has just merged
with genesis care
genesis care is one of the largest
oncology providers worldwide based out
of
australia they're responsible for
treating over four hundred thousand
cancer patients
worldwide in australia spain
the united kingdom and the united states
we have over 5 500 health care providers
and ancillary staff and
the company is very committed to
investing a lot of money
not only in technology so we have the
latest
cancer therapies but also um
staff so we have excellent providers to
provide the
best cancer care available the question
is
what sets genesis care apart from the
rest when it comes to cancer care
they're all about patient-centered care
everything's about the patient
we do everything we can to make the care
convenient
multi-disciplinary and it's really just
patient-centered care we realize the
needs of the individuals supersede the
disease
process so we really focus on doing
what's best for the patient
with that said 21st century oncology
becoming genesis care is taking cancer
treatment for our southern nevada
communities
to the next level they're investing in
innovation
people and technology to drive the best
possible clinical outcomes
for our cancer patients it's going to
give
southern nevada access to high quality
health care
without delay no delays in cancer care
and earlier treatment will lead to
better outcomes and during covet 19 it's
especially important to remember this
people should not put cancer treatment
or screenings
on hold i personally have had some
patients stop therapy
so the biggest obstacle to care has been
patients understandably have been
scared to go get their necessary cancer
screening tests in therapy
but like the virus the
cancer can be deadly and these are not
optional
tests people should be getting so that's
really something
we've tried to overcome by creating a
safe environment
[Music]
for more information call
just visit 702-243-3340